where'd you grow up I grew up in New
Orleans
seriously yeah wow how do we not know
that uh-oh spoke the dog there
um
I don't know I don't know I should have
mentioned that earlier but yeah the
first thing I should have mentioned when
I met you guys yeah
um when did you leave New Orleans uh I
started comedy and there's there's no
comedy there so you had to get out and
move so I moved here within like six
months or something so you were there
for Hurricane Katrina I was at LSU which
is Louisiana State University which is
in Baton Rouge and that's about an hour
away but my family was there the whole
thing the house was ruined and all my
friends houses got ruined it was a dark
time it has a really dark time man yeah
we've that Hurricane Katrina was in 2005
I think like maybe August or something
yeah and uh the following year like
early in the following year 2006 we shot
a bunch of Jackass number two in uh
Louisiana oh really yeah and it was just
still [ __ ]
tore up it was yeah it was it was a
gnarly why did you guys choose that
place to film then uh primarily because
we'd had such a great experience filming
wild boys there and I think that they
were just doing a lot of movie
production there because of like uh tax
breaks like uh like the Norland
Louisiana in general has been a big
destination for filmmaking oh yeah okay
more and more I worked on Benjamin
buttons uh as a I worked on a couple
movies in Louisiana because I was a pit
yeah because I was just a movie nerd so
I was like I'll block the street or I'll
be that guy I'll be a gopher wow and
that was awesome I got to see Benjamin
buttons film probably 2006 seven so it
was right after Katrina the whole city
was [ __ ] and they the movie Magic they
got stuff going they're like we need A
Streetcar and they're like well the
streetcars are out of commission they
said well we can get one working so they
got one working for the movie and you're
like the city can't do this but
Hollywood can yeah I think um that
there's really a big component too of
like like
being deliberate about going to film in
Louisiana because of Hurricane Katrina
because that business is going to help
them rebuild so yeah like uh it's it's a
good thing yeah I went to the uh the
Superdome to help out like the old
people and all that and I had to help an
old guy [ __ ] and I still think about
that all the time just he pulled his
pants down and I'm like lowering him out
of the bowl and his old balls were
dangling and I had to wipe his ass yeah
it was like the first time I did
something for someone else you know what
was this for well Hurricane Katrina all
these people were like displaced yeah
but like would you you joined FEMA and
they're like well does it help other
people out this girl I was trying to
sleep with was uh helping so I was like
I'll help you there yeah so uh I only
did it for her but
I got laid Yeah it was worth it yeah it
reminds me of the story when we were
talking about that that you helped that
guy put the kids yeah I was just
thinking about that dude listen to this
story dude it was uh I had a buddy who
was um
paraplegic
funny dude yeah oh my God we laughed so
hard with uh Travis Pastrana about this
because he was in a wheelchair and uh he
he needed help
um
putting the catheter in his in his
weiner oh God but then we but then I
realized that he'd like uh he was
paraplegic like he oh he didn't feel no
no he had the use of his hands
yeah she's like dude you didn't have to
do that because the guy could do it
himself that's hilarious no uh here I
was I was actually holding his his
wiener with one hand and feeding the
catheter with the other hand like I was
being a great guy yeah
and uh that guy's got a hell of a story
for later you're not gonna believe it
you're not the only person who's done
that where was this at
we were uh we were like going around
getting hammered in New York City as I
recall
who you and this guy yeah yeah
I I think that because I remember he had
trouble rolling up a a dollar bill to
snort coke with too
who is this guy awesome guy you met I
mean I I don't need to be like super
specific about who he is but uh yeah
he's a buddy of mine
it was Stephen Hawking
[Laughter]
it's called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude